when it comes to the world of pc
peripherals there is perhaps
nothing more coveted mythologized
and
all-consuming
than mechanical keyboards it's gotten so
deep that if you don't have one yourself
you are led to believe that you are
categorically missing out that there is
a hole in your life that can only be
filled by a rectangular slab of plastic
and metal mechanical keyboards have
quite literally become the king of all
pc components
so
why the hell haven't we made a cracked
about them yet
they are by far the most actively talked
about subjects in the peripheral sphere
and for good reason sure you can argue
that other pieces of one setup are more
integral to one's overall experience but
there is nothing more personalized and
customizable than your keyboard
this is actually the most disgusting
thing i've ever seen but that also means
that the mechanical keyboard community
can be a
little fanatical since there is
basically no ceiling for how unique your
keyboard can be you can fall down a
rabbit hole that could end up costing
you a pretty penny in fact it's one of
those very few diy hobbies in which it
actually costs more to simply build the
damn thing yourself
a lot more your bundle is going to be
your bundle will be 810
bills is that a lot that is a lot of
money that being said it is quite
impressive how far keyboard tech has
come in the last few years
the question of course
is
is any of it worth it are all the
clickety clackety switches rgb settings
and custom keycaps just
filler have we strayed too far from the
intended function of keyboards which is
just to you know
type and since this is a cracked
we gotta know
do mechanical keyboards actually provide
gamers with any sort of
competitive edge
[Applause]
all right so before we start talking
about keebs and all that good stuff i
must do the thing where i ask that you
please like the video subscribe to the
channel and turn on notifications i must
also ask that you please check out our
twitch channel where we've actually been
watch partying all sorts of fun valorant
events and presumably down the line
other events as well just
gotta get those permissions okay so in
order to reach the insane point that we
are at now where mechanical keyboards
are the gold standard we need to go way
back to the beginning of esports when
if you were around back then your
keyboard probably looked
like this and it was near the tail end
of that era that we were blessed with
the holy grail of all og keyboards the
ibm model m in fact those keyboards were
so well made that there is actually
still a sort of niche group of die hards
who continue to restore and use them
yes i have an ibm model m keyboard i
actually found it by accident in a
thrift store and had no idea what it was
until after i bought it but the buckling
spring switches in this bad boy are a
truly unique typing experience under
each key is a physical spring that
buckles as the name suggests and
actuates a press onto a contact layer
underneath while this technically makes
it a membrane keyboard the physical
feedback is just
one of a kind that isn't to say the ibm
model m was the be-all and end-all for
keyboards used for gaming but this
non-mechanical beast gave us a very
early window into what was possible in
reality any and all keyboards can be and
have been used for gaming that's part of
what makes their fandom so interesting
in fact it wasn't really until the late
2000s that companies wisened up and
started taking a deliberate approach to
making peripherals specifically for
gamers and one of the companies that
emerged as a sort of gaming peripheral
powerhouse was logitech when they
launched their now legendary g series
lineup rg series products are known for
performance and function they're
designed to work flawlessly so you can
concentrate on the game and not worry
about the technology one of logitech's
big early successes was the release of
the g15 in 2007.
a couple years later the design would be
improved with a digital display in the
g19 a large part of its popularity came
down to its added programmable buttons
and many other companies would soon
follow its design now it's important to
note that up until this point the
logitech lineup was made up of membrane
keyboards not mechanical ones meaning
that when the keys are pressed down they
push a small rubber button that
activates the switch and so that begs
the question
what the hell is a mechanical keyboard
like how do these things work and
where did they come from well what makes
a mechanical keyboard different is that
it uses switches which
operate like
well a switch the key is pushed down a
small prong is moved and the switch is
activated sending a signal to your pc
when released the spring pushes the key
back into place cutting the signal
though there may have been mechanical
keyboards prior the ones we know and
love today are all thanks to the cherry
mx key switches which despite reaching
peak popularity in and around 2010 were
actually patented all the way back in
1984.
this is the cherry kxn 3-8451
infrared keyboard introduced in 1984 at
a price of 275 us dollars and yes this
is a wireless mechanical keyboard from
the mid-80s and it's awesome as for
underneath the keys well this is where
the mechanical stuff happens these are
cherry mx blacks or rather some early
variant of them that were introduced the
same year as this keyboard in 1984. and
these switches didn't just pave the way
they are to this day the switches most
manufacturers either use or try to
emulate and in 2014 one company did
emulate the cherry mx switches so well
in fact that the keyboard in which they
were implemented which previously ran
cherry mx switches went on to become one
of the most popular mechanical keyboards
of all time i am of course talking about
the razer black widow
[Music]
for starters it was much more accessible
than pretty much any other gamer
marketed mechanical keyboard you could
find a black widow at pretty much any
big box store or tech outlet and since
it was basically the first keyboard to
be marketed on the merits of its custom
bespoke knockoff razer green switches it
was a really formative product one that
would set the pace for the consumer
grade mechanical keyboard market for
years to come on top of that it
eventually allowed for more
customization the black widow of course
had the signature rgb settings that let
you turn your desk into a vegas slot
machine and you could even get different
style of razer's switches to best suit
your needs out of the box as a result
the black widow absolutely exploded and
for a lot of gamers it was likely their
first introduction to mechanical
keyboards this also helped kick off the
trend of peripheral companies creating
their own lines of gamer gear in an
attempt to corner the market someone
cover me yeah i see you you got him you
got him he got him
yes
yo
that's sweet yeah it is we about to win
this
but why was it working why were people
tossing out their perfectly functioning
membrane keyboards for mechanical ones
well part of it is good old marketing
magic but more significantly people were
starting to fall in love with the idea
of
simply using a mechanical switch the
sound the feeling i still remember
walking into a canada computers in 2014
opening the flap on that black widow box
and clicking a green switch for the
first time
it was
there was nothing else like it it was
all anyone wanted now that clicky clacky
noise we love so much comes from the
type of switch that's being used on the
key a switch doesn't thawk by default
depending on what the user prefers
there's all types of sounds and
sensations they can achieve some can be
completely silent but others
like
mine that's right i'm a psychopath who
loves clicky switches
might wake up your neighbors
did that upset you
and now the guy who actually knows what
he's talking about did somebody say loud
switches
honestly i like my model m because it's
simple there's a million and one
different key switches these days and it
can be genuinely head spinning just
trying to pin down which one has the
feel that you're actually looking for so
let's break down some of the things to
look for in a switch for those of us who
don't currently have an entire soldering
workstation and drawers full of
keyswitches which is me too so we're all
in this together fellow normies first
let's talk about tactile versus linear
switches linear switches actuate with no
physical feedback a consistent amount of
force gives you consistent motion
through to bottom out tactile switches
by contrast have a bump at the actuation
point requiring some extra force to
engage the switch this gives your finger
physical feedback so that you know when
the switch has actually been engaged and
tactile switches exist on a gradient so
you have plenty of choices for how
strong you want that actuation feedback
to be there's also the spring tension or
operating force which measures how hard
you have to push a key to make it move
often people describe this as how heavy
or light the keys are another very
important piece is the travel distance
of the switch both how far the switch
moves until actuating and the total
distance that it can travel too long a
travel distance and you'll have a hard
time with rapid repeated key presses too
short a travel distance and you'll just
end up bottoming out all the time and
losing a lot of the feel of a mechanical
switch essentially the difference
between typing on a full keyboard and a
laptop keyboard whatever type of feeling
and sound profile you're looking for
from your keyboard whether it's cherry
mx or some other brand there are
switches out there to fit and that was
the guy who actually knows what he's
talking about but clicking like a
typewriter can't be the only reason that
people are buying them surely if gamers
are the biggest market for these things
they have to provide some type of
advantage right well theoretically yes
but it might actually not be that
important
you see one of the main selling points
of a mechanical keyboard is that they
last a hell of a lot longer than your
run-of-the-mill membrane board even
mass-manufactured black widows can last
10 years any competitive advantage is
owed to the fact that mechanical
keyboards also boast an extremely fast
response time due to the nature of how
the switches operate that keystroke
input signal is getting sent to your pc
faster than any other type of keyboard
and in competitive gaming where
literally every millisecond counts being
confident that your inputs are going to
register exactly when you want is
extremely important to some it's so
important that companies have been able
to use response times as a selling
feature whether it's razer corsair
logitech or whoever every manufacturer
is coming out with new switches that
claim to have a faster response time
than their competitors optical switches
on the other hand such as corsair's opx
switches use a small beam of infrared
light that's pointed at an ir sensor
that passes through the switch enclosure
to complete the circuit corsair's
optical switches are among the fastest
switches you can find with zero debounce
and a short actuation distance of just
one millimeter how much of this is just
marketing
hard to say although switches can be
tested down to fractions of a second the
best ones for gaming might just come
down to preference more than anything
else what you need to ask yourself is if
that's enough to sell you on picking up
a mechanical keyboard because that's
basically the only gaming related
benefit well save for one other thing
you see there is an argument to be made
that the main draw of a mechanical
keyboard the clickiness
is actually the biggest benefit for
gamers on top of being either fantastic
or annoying to listen to the tactile
feel of a mechanical keyboard is
extremely alluring the god of all things
keeb teja types has spoken at length
about what he sees as mechanical
keyboards most important aspect it's not
the response times or the longevity it
is a return to something more
raw and expressive we often fill our
senses with rich flavors and pleasant
aromas
but how often do we take care of the
things we touch
to me the mechanical keyboard is a
tactile gateway to the computers we
build our lives around especially in
this digital day and age since you can
feel every single input the keyboard
sort of becomes an extension of your
body the same way a mouse fits to the
shape of your hand imagine counter
strafing in cs go but with a membrane
keyboard it would feel like [ __ ] you
want your movement to be precise perfect
to the touch and for that it's really
helpful to have a mechanical switch
mechanical keyboards have become this
perfect blend of form and function not
just something that will stand the test
of time or give you the response time
you need but something that legitimately
feels rewarding to use which in my
opinion is more important than anything
else
now
that would be a pretty good place to end
today's video unfortunately there is one
tiny little very expensive subject we
still need to cover
custom keyboards like we mentioned at
the start custom keyboards are a
peripheral revolution in their own right
it's becoming more and more common for
people to now ditch their retail
mechanical keyboards for something a
little more
personalized we're going to suffocate
this pcb with some pe foam we're going
to
tape this keyboard shut as well because
we're trying to make this
perfect here we have it
the
most degenerate
keyboard that i've ever built so far
to boil it down keyboards pretty much
come in three price points you have your
cheaper more entry-level boards that you
can find on amazon between 100 and 150
bucks then you have your more premium
logitechs and corsairs with added
features that typically start at around
250
after that you start to get into custom
territory and those puppies can go
anywhere from three hundred dollars to
thousands of dollars the sky is truly
the limit with these things does look
cool feel like i'm about to crack the
code this thing is heavy
oh
boy look
[Music]
it's a real typewriter feel but these
custom keyboards aren't just expensive
for the sake of being expensive
well i mean they can be but they also
provide a level of customization and
personalization that does not exist
anywhere else in the world of
peripherals you want different switches
for different keys
go nuts you want a literal
20 pound hunk of metal as your keyboard
do you my dude
you want anime keycaps
don't do that literally do anything but
that
all right that feels a little personal
basically if you can think it you can
keep it there are even those who've
opted to sacrifice a style for
functionality but remember kids
just because you can
doesn't mean you should your scientists
were so preoccupied with whether or not
they could they didn't stop to think
they should the custom keyboard
marketplace has gotten so big that this
simple matter of upgrading your setup
has become not just a hobby but even a
potential career path now before you get
too excited i must remind you for the
umpteenth time custom mechanical
keyboards can be very very expensive
and past a certain point you will have
capped functionality and are basically
just adding [ __ ] because it's cool which
is completely fine just know your limits
and don't go out and buy the most
expensive switches or keyboard because
you think it's going to make you a
better gamer
any entry-level mechanical board is
going to do a lot better than a 20
dollar membrane board hell faker could
probably pull off the same [ __ ] with a
100 ducky that he could with the most
expensive custom board actually he'd
probably be just as good with an apple
keyboard now that isn't to say you
shouldn't consider upgrading to a custom
keyboard when it comes to all of the
peripherals out there a unique keyboard
can be one of the most rewarding
additions to your setup especially if
you build it yourself what is important
is that you do your own research and
figure out what works for you what you
like not what other people or other
manufacturers tell you to like that's
the beauty of keyboards they can be
anything you want them to be so make it
what you want it to be
let's get rid of the clicks there oh i
unplugged my keyboard
i know right
i do have a ducky somewhere
that is still has blues on them because
i use clickys but i don't use blues i
use uh kale gold speed switches
so they're clickys but they're not like
they have a nicer sound and
i uh i should try the without the blues
again
my girlfriend's gonna shoot me
never gonna what